ouais parce que sinon il faut que elles
ont décidé d'afficher la couleur elles
ont choisi d'être ambassadrice contre le
harcèlement c'est elle qui colle qui
fixe comme une promesse ce trèfle vert
il représente l'engagement des
collégiens à lutter contre ce fléau et
pour que cela se voit il repartent avec
un bracelet pour moi c'est très
important parce que
je l'ai vécu et je sais que ça fait mal
donc j'aime pas voir les autres souffrir
d'un même souffrance que j'ai vécu donc
c'est très important pour moi de
communiquer l'info entre les enfants et
les adultes montre qu'aux personnes que
ils sont harcelés que on est là pour eux
et qu'on les supporte
autre action de cette journée
particulière toutes les classes prennent
une heure pour réfléchir s'informer
échanger à partir de sondages ou de
vidéos
[Musique]
mettre des mots sur des gestes des
paroles cela permet de comprendre ce que
veut dire être victime ou bien même
harceleur
il se demandait pourquoi il avait fait
ça parce que c'était juste pour rigoler
avec ses copains du coup il est mort
harceleur victime mais aussi spectateurs
60% de la classe a été confronté à ce
phénomène
il y a quelque chose qui est tout simple
mais qui casse cette logique ce triangle
infernal c'est de dire tout simplement
sans dire oui arrête c'est pas bien
j'aime pas te dire moi ça me met mal à
l'aise quand tu dis ça à un thème pour
ces ambassadrices parler ce n'est pas
toujours suffisant toutes les quatre ont
été harcelés d'une façon ou d'une autre
moi je pense que tout dépend de chaque
harceleur tout dépend de la du caractère
de chacun il y en a où il y aura il y
aura plus besoin de sanctions que de
discours et il y en a qui vont apprendre
conscience et d'autres non
malheureusement on va jusqu'à la
sanction quand l'élève ne prend pas
ne reconnaît pas ses fautes et
persistent dans ses agissements depuis
mars 2022 le harcèlement est devenu un
délit puni pour les mineurs de un an et
demi jusqu'à trois ans d'emprisonnement